Pro six circuits on uh tiny binary data
sets so what we'll do today is actually
um train PCS on uh language language
models and hung is going to tell us how
that works and what that's useful
for so um today I'll present our paper
uh tractable control for autor
regressive language
Generation Um so um unlike probably um
the interesting ones today I'll focus
more on the application side of
problemistic circuits like more machine
learning
oriented okay so uh let's get started
with the basic uh concept of large
language
models um they have been like really
popular recently I'm not sure if people
here really care or not um
like I see like um disinterested face do
okay that's a good sign that's a good
sign um so basically the idea is very um
simple in the sense that you collect
large amount of text consisting of
trillions of words and you train neuron
networks with billions of parameters on
these data then you have these so-called
large language models um um this chat
GPT or GPT 4 thing has become like like
really popular like like people talking
to them on the Internet asking them to
to publish their papers uh using them to
do their homeworks and even asking them
like to um to like play D and D like
together so yeah uh that is actually
true um so so the idea is so so people
have have now having this feeling that
we oh we probably have solved AI we have
solved um artificial intelligence
um and chat GPT has passed touring test
but is that really the the case Okay so
so I I tried this uh um a few few months
ago U it was an actual like uh a
conversation between me and chpt so so I
asked the model to generate a sentence
using frisbee Cod and dog following the
given order well I mean this should be
quite simple for for a super intelligent
AI model right so it does give me a
sentence um the sentence look quite
decent and all the keywords are are in
there but dog and C are in the wrong
order right well I mean humans make
mistakes so super intelligent AI does so
I was being patient I I try it again
okay again it gives me a sentence but
it's even worse now all of the words are
are in the WR order so so you see that
trpt um fails to follow even the simple
logical constraint okay so people have
been trying to fix this um some of the
methods like including like okay we can
prompt them in a different way like like
chain Chain of Thought um I'm not
comfortable saying this phrase but
that's one of the methods um or people
try to like use search algorithms trying
to find the correct sentence in this
huge search space so on and so forth but
none of them actually guarantees that
chat GPT or whatever other language
model give us uh what we want so what we
actually want is like 100% guarantee
when we have like a huge powerful model
when we instructed to do something we
wanted to follow our con uh instructions
exactly so so in today's talk um I'll
show you how we can do this with
probabilistic
circuits um before um some of the detail
um so let's get started with some basics
of language modeling so language
modeling is really not like a fancy idea
it's just a join distribution over some
text uh probably less than or equal to
to
nword um each random variable here is uh
is um a word taking value um in a fixed
uh in a vocabulary of finite uh size uh
the size usually in practice ranges from
10,000 to 50,000 something
okay and uh here are some some examples
uh you might notice there's some special
uh word called EOS here which means end
of sentence which is only like a special
token or word we use to pad sentence
sentences of different lengths to the
maximum length so we have this like
joint distribution well defined okay so
we collect a lot of text uh of this form
uh sentence fragments paragraph
fragments and we uh train this joint
distribution by maximizing lock
likelihood a very very simple idea okay
so what about the architecture of this
distribution of our model well uh like
the most popular ones U like GPT they
they are Auto regressive models well so
by by the uh chain rule of probability
we can decompose our join distribution U
this
way um represented uh as a graphical
model is basically for each uh random
variable we have arrows going from all
the previous uh random
variables uh from a generative point of
view um it's basically we start uh with
uh I can't see my cursor so so we start
um generating the first uh word from
this prior distribution once we have the
first word we move on to the second one
conditioning on the first one and then
we generate the third one conditioning
on the first two words very simple
okay um by some uh Classic results uh
marginals for for these uh for basan
networks with these structures is is
intractable
okay
um okay
so so before when we asked GPT to
generate a sentence for us we are like
talking to it as if it's human right so
the assumption is if our distribution
over language is a perfect distribution
then we should be able to interact it
with with it as a
human um when we're doing this kind of
like prompting when we're talking to it
most of the time we are actually trying
to do conditioning so let's consider
even simpler example um suppose in our
Auto regressive generation we have
generated the first three words uh the
weather is and our constraint is that we
want the sentence to contain the keyword
winter well I mean we want to write
something with the topic of winter so
that's our
constraint um what we really want is um
okay so so what language model gives us
is the next token next word probability
so basically given the weather is it
might prefer whether like it's warm or
cold well it's prior distribution might
might want the weather to be warm um but
what we actually
want uh but what actually need is this
conditional next word probability right
we we want our sentence toci satisfy the
constraint once to contain the
winter and while intuitively if we want
the winter to be in the sentence the
weather is more likely to be code
okay but this is intractable for um
those Auto regressive
models so why is it intractable let's go
more into the details so by base rule um
this conditional probability can be
decomposed into these two
terms um the next term here is very
simple it's just a language model next
word probability but the first uh term
here is actually a marginal probability
so it's basically the marginal
probability over all possible suffixes
that we could generate that contains
winter
okay so this is intractable for auto
regressive models but we have PCS right
uh PCS are tractable at least
um we know how to compute marginal
probabilities with them so why don't we
just uh approximate um this term here
with problemistic
circuits and uh we refer to our uh
pipeline as uh gelato um and generating
language with tractable
constraints um okay so how do how do we
do this so so the first step is that we
pick our favorite uh PC for sequential
modeling which is a hidden markup model
the simplest we can
have we um have on the other on the
other hand we have our pre-trained
language model we want to control or
guide we sample a lot of data from our
language model unconditionally and then
we train our hidden markup model on
these data with with maximum likelihood
estimation so effectively minimizing the
K Divergence between the two joint
distributions and our assumption is that
if the joint distributions are close
enough then all of the marginal
distributions and conditional
distributions are going to be
similar okay um any questions okay so so
the intuition is that we have like the
blackbox auto regressive model and we
train some sort of white box PC so we
can kind of use as
a as a representative of of the blackbox
okay so but we don't want to um since
this is the workshop for circuits and
logic uh let's represent uh hmm as PCS
so here's the graphical model version of
PC uh the Z's here are the uh hidden
variables theat variables um and the X
here are the observed variables are the
words and uh let me use the Whiteboard
um to show you how to do
this okay so okay so one assumption we
have is that our um hidden States or
latent
variables are discrete variables taking
values from one to H and H is our hidden
State any
questions okay so we start from the very
beginning in then hmm we start with the
initial State Z1 and it has uh H
Choices so we want these um eight
product nodes to be representing the
prob probability can people see it
actually so representing the probability
of X1 um to n conditioning on Z1 equals
to
I so I would be the hidden state so I
will this will be one two and
H okay and the and the edge will have
weights of the prior Distribution on
Z1
sense okay I see nodding I see con
confusing faces but I'll move on
whatever um okay so um it'll be clear
later so um so given so by the markal
property given Z1 X1 and so basically
given Z1 this part and the remaining
part will be independent so let's deal
with X1
first
um we have some input
distributions and this input
distribution will be representing the
probability the emission probability
basically X1 given Z1 =
I okay so basically here we're in the
states of Z1 equal to 1 and this will
represent the probability of X1 given
that Z1 equal to one
okay um I see more nodding faces
now
um okay and we want this part to
describe the remaining distributions so
we have some notes
here and they will
represent the
distribution the
distribution of P of X2 to n given
[Music]
Z corresponding to their inputs and uh
so we proceed the next
layer and this part will be the
transition
probabilities will be the transition
probability of Z2 equals to J given z i
Z1 equals to I and these will
recursively we we do this construction
recursively will be representing the
probability from X2 to n conditioning on
Z2 equals to
I okay does that make sense so we just
proceed so it's
uh um like like Antonio and Robert was
was trying to to make the point this is
a tensorized layer representation of a
PC
okay um let's move on okay so now we
have
our oh
sorry um so let let's move on so we have
our circuit representing the
distribution um over text then we need
to to answer the question we need to
encode The Logical constraint as a
logical
circuit so let's go back to the to the
um to the constraint we have in the very
beginning we want frisbee dog and
dog uh Frisby Cott and dog to appear in
the given order
um this is a like a naive way to
represent this constraint um basically
the J JK here
are
enumerating all possible positions of of
these three words and we take a
conjunction whenever we when when we uh
know the positions um any any
questions okay okay but this is not
really ideal we can directly convert it
into a to a PC that represents the
constraint
but
um what are the what are the problems do
people see
that
um I'll give a hint um complexity what's
the complexity of of this what's the
size of this
dnf yes cubic cubic and to be more
precise it's n choose number of keywords
right well I mean we can do it like
cubic but suppose we have five or 10
keywords we can no longer take that
complexity okay and the other problem is
more subtle which is that
this this uh dnf is not deterministic
okay so we know that we can multiply
circuits when they are compatible or
when they're structur decomposable with
respect to the same V tree but here we
want exact conditioning so we actually
need to do need to make sure that our
circuit
represents a uniform distribution over
the support specified by
this um
dnf and um in general um it is M it is
Sharpie hard to do model counting to
normalize everything okay I I'll I'll go
into the details on the
board
yes yes I'll talk about it on on on the
board um um can I
okay I I'll move to the other
side okay so
um so for the first question why does it
need to be deterministic is because so
okay suppose we have a
very um okay so suppose we have a very
simple distribution
X1
X2
we have some
weights we have some so this is a
distribution over two random variables
okay and this is its probability Mass
function
um so when we are conditioning we're
actually selecting all the terms that
satisfy our constraint and zeroing out
everything else right so if we do if we
want to do that with circuit
multiplication suppose our constraint
our support would be something like X1
X2 and
X um one bar X2 okay so the constraint
circuit
[Music]
um should be a uniform distribution over
its support otherwise it messes up with
uh the original weights right does that
make
sense okay so however um okay let let me
so this will be 0.5 X1 X2
Plus
well I mean um suppose
um and we have a bunch of zeros and we
multiply these two two circuits
pointwise and we kind um we keep these
two terms and erase these two terms
right but we want W and W3 to be
proportional to each other like the
ratio to stay the same so this circuit
must be a uniform distribution over the
support of the constraint okay so given
logical circuit how do we convert it
into a PC that represents a uniform
distribution over the
support to do that we need to do model
counting but model counting in general
is hard if determinism is
missing so um this one won't
work does that make
sense yes no Robert
isn't that
atic oh yeah so so it's a very subtle
subtle thing so
um well we only require fisb CAU and dog
to appear in some positions but we do
not limit that they have to appear
exactly once so you can totally have
frisbee
Cod C dog dog something like this so we
have two
subsequences we have a lot of
subsequences
right so um this is position 1 2 3 4
five
six so when j j k are 1 3
five it satisfies uh the Clauses right
one of
right okay uh let me uh choose a
different way okay so so basically for
this huge djunction for each
instantiation to the variable we only
satisfy one of the Clauses right we want
that's
determinism yes and uh suppose I J KR
135 does this instance satisfy that yes
it does right but when ik j
kr14 five it also satisfies that so it's
not DET does that make
sense okay okay okay so now let's
construct the deterministic circuit
representing this
constraint the idea is similar to a a
deterministic finite
automata it's basically you track how
many words have you included how many
words have you used which state are you
in satisfying
strength so we want to construct these
sub formulas Fe
T say
Cod and
dog the sub formula representing the
constraint
that Cod and
dog
appears
in XT XT +
[Music]
1 okay so how do we construct this
subcircuit or this sub formula well it's
pretty simple it's a sum node we
consider two different
cases one of the cases that XT is
cot and the other case is
that XT is not
C does just make sense okay so if XT is
CAU then we have have like stepped
one um we have made one step toward
satisfying the constraint
okay so we can reduce it to t +
1 and suppose XT is not cod we're in the
same state so we reduce it to t + one
C
is that clear so suppose we have
constructed Fe for all
all time step greater than T then we can
construct all the fees for T
right okay so it's a recursive
algorithm
um oh what's the base case yes that's
very
interesting
um should I okay I'm going to eras
this just cop and in product so yeah I
mean we can make it even simpler um I'm
lazy so I want to make things
simple um so suppose in the N
position um we only have one word
right so Fe
and
uh
what is this formula means
that from xn to xn we need to have coton
dog so this is false right
zero
um what if we only have dog so this is
true only if x
[Music]
xn Okay so yeah those are the base
cases okay so how many so what's the
size of the
circuit so at each time
step we need
VT maybe we have already satisfied the
constraint
so something empty right we need
ft um we we have one word left BT we
have coton Dot we have two work
left and we have generated none of them
yet okay so at each time step we
have four Su notes or four or or notes
representing all these four
cases and um the size the number of
nodes in the circuit would be four
times hey does that make
sense and you can notice that when we
are constructing this circuit we are
always conditioning on XT current
variable which is very similar to hmm it
generates one variable at a time one
word at a time so it is compatible with
hmm and also it's
deterministic and we can do the apply
operation the product operation
layerwise so the size of the event
circuit would be
for so originally so
originally here for each layer we have H
nodes now we here for each layer we had
four nodes So eventually we have four h
nodes each
layer
acceptable okay does that make
sense so we can still generate this um
we can generate this even further
well some sometime well one one simple
generalization is you might think it
doesn't have to be Cod right it can be
called or either catch right or C
catches they all kind of represent the
same concept
so in the construction we
can modify our original circuit a little
bit before it was
xtal
C we can replace it with another or
node enumerating Cod catch and catches
okay and the circuit size stays roughly
the
same and there are many other things we
can do we can also say oh we we don't
need them to be in the same order in the
fixed order we can we want them to be
like in arbitrary order we don't care
about the order how do we do that so so
in this case we have four states right
basically um enumerating all suffixes of
these three keywords in that case we
would have all subsets of the three
keyword so in that way the complexity
would
[Music]
be going from four we have three keyword
since it's four to 2 to the three there
eight so
still acceptable to to the N is not
really um say we have 10 keywords two to
the it's just 1024 it's still doable in
practice yes so it seems uh that you can
do any kind of regular expression
constraint but you're you're focusing
here on uh languages of fixed length
right because you
have a fixed number of of RAM and VAR
Ables yes so is that the kind of
equivalent of what you're what you're
saying yes yes that's a very very good
point so fixed length here is a very is
a very essential assumption so suppose
we have a distribution over length over
language of arbitrary length then
applying the constraint could be hard to
Define so they so basically these three
words they can appear in arbitrarily far
positions and we need probably need to
take like an infinite sum to Define this
conditional
probability but this is not um terrible
in practice because in practice even for
models like GPT they have a finite um SE
yeah that's a very good
point okay uh try to be
fast well I mean there are variations of
constraint we have talked about
um and okay so so now we have
our sorry now we we have our uh
probalistic circuit representing the
distribution and we have our constraint
circuit and we close them to take the
product so we have our constraint
circuit now we can compute the
probabilities we need so the step two is
very simple so this is original um like
base decomposition of the conditional
probability we have so this term here is
intractable so we secretly replace the
subscript of LM with hmm no one will
notice and we Define this
uh conditional uh distribution the
gelato
distribution and we can compute this
with the linear pass of the the
C
okay so what are the advantages um so
number one by definition the constraint
Alpha is guaranteed to be satisfied so
finally other than compared to the all
the other methods we we have 100%
reliable thing we can trust and number
two is that the training of this this
hmm is um does not depend on the
constraint so basically once we have
this hmm trained we can use it to enfor
whatever constraint we want okay so so
maybe today I want to write something
using some keywords and key Concepts and
tomorrow I feel like this language model
is
like um using a lot of inappropriate
languages and we can detoxify it by
specifying a list of bad words to that
it cannot use okay and all the same
model and all the constraints are only
in U enforced at inference
time yes what kind of constraints can be
presented as
decomposable
species yes uh that's a very very good
question that's actually one of the main
reason I'm presenting this work here
because um my feeling is that though
people have been studying like
probalistic queries like marginal map uh
marginal
um and and and all these kinds of stuff
uh extensively
but in practice we really care about
like some more complicated less generic
ones and whether is there a language to
define or to describe their tractability
is like um kind of missing from the
literature but um I could relate this to
like say there's some work on compiling
um uh DFAS uh to circuits I think that
that could be something uh as a starting
point to look at I'm not sure if that
answers your question I don't have an
answer my answer is okay
okay so so experiments and benchmarks um
so we we um evaluate our method on this
Common Sense generation common gem
Benchmark well um it's very similar to
the example I gave you it give you a
bunch of keywords and uh each example
comes with a bunch of like gold uh
sentences and you want to generate
something that that looks similar to the
to the gold sentences using using
keywords and here uh
it's like the most General case so
basically these keywords they can appear
in any order and um they can appear in
any form of their
inflections okay
so this
is and it's a g gigantic table the
numbers themselves are not that
important
um so one thing to note that is compared
to all the other baselines um our method
gelato model achieves uh
state-of-the-art performance with
respect to basically all metrics so
these metrics here rou L blue for ciders
spice State they are just some like
standard NLP metrics that people use to
eval to evaluate the quality of your
text so basically you have a gold
sentence and you have your generated
sentence they compute somehow the NR
overlap to measure the
quality
um but the other thing is that all of
the previous method
um cannot uh achieve 100% constraint
satisfiability but ours does in practice
as well well there's this one Baseline
they they achieve 100% accuracy as well
but they kind of did it
by starting from from the keywords so
they're never they're always going to be
there and you can see their their
generation quality is really poor
so um we also conducted some sort of
human
evaluation okay I guess yes which
language model does that use
oh uh the language model we use gpd2
gpt2 large yeah and all of the baselines
they they use gpd2 large yeah
okay and and in case people don't really
trust these automatic evaluation metrics
we also conducted human
evaluation
um um and you can see that our model
performs U much better than previous
state
of okay are this significant I mean
they're pretty close uh yeah so yeah so
basically
the I'm not sure if you can see it
clearly but the B faced ones are like
statistically uh
significantly what what equivalent so so
these ones these two are statistically
equivalent uh this this one is
statistically
significant and one to five ratings what
what's the what's the number here oh
yeah so basically we we provide the
annotator some sentence and uh we
provide description of the of one of
each of the aspects so basic concepts
means that does it use all the concepts
naturally and plausibility means that is
the sentence like a plausible sentence
describing a realistic scene and quality
is basically fluency grammar and stuff
overall is the like another how do you
feel about the sentence and the and the
numbers are from one to three one
three
okay um okay so let's uh get back to the
uh the very first motivating example and
you can see that gelato we used our
model to act and it is actually able to
get everything correct and generate a
fluent
sentence um and another uh I don't okay
show so so we also found this one in one
of the generated candidates a pair of
frisbee players are caught in a dog
fight which is not like the this like
the the thing that that that most people
would like think of so it's still it
also shows some some sort of uh
creativity
here okay uh that that's my my talk uh
please ask questions if you have and
otherwise we can go to
[Applause]
lunch more
[Music]
questions thanks for talk if I
understand right you said that uh to
generate every word you have to do a
linear pass over the uh circuit so how
much is this overhead compared to the
kind of latency from the language model
okay I I I like I like that question so
so we don't really need to take a pass
over the whole circuit with some uh
caching we can do like constant time um
so so basically to generate each word
the cost is like constant time it's like
a pass through one
layer I see and then in practice how how
fast is that fast is uh we actually so
um
um wait I don't have a table here but we
have a table in the paper so so if say
generating a sentence
with um five keywords uh a GPD too large
would take uh around 20 seconds and our
method is like a 100ish seconds so it's
it's not terrible
and one of the the baselines here well
which was actually like a best paper
award at one of the top NLB conferences
they use search based method and and for
them to generate a sentence they they
take like 700 seconds 800 seconds so
because they're search based so when the
search Bas gets gets large they're
they're yeah their method shows like a
Bott in terms
of
can you also give an idea about the the
time required to derive the hidden
Market model so yeah so I do have the
time for that so so our hidden Markov
model has like uh 4,000 States and the
emission is
50,000 we trained them with the with the
juice framework that we develop there a
lot um we s um the training takes like
20 hours so it's
um we Sample about
um we sample 8 million sentences from
GPT and we trained them for
40s 20
hours what's number of parameters number
of
parameters hm yeah so so hmm is 4,000
hidden States and 50,000
uh emissions so the the M the mainly
that the parameters are centered on the
emission table so it's like 40,000 4,000
time
50,000 I couldn't do that in my head
those are unique parameters right yes
yeah yes so so in the PC yes you kind of
like you roll out all the parameters at
all
positions so controllable controllable
generation is huge right so this is
great um what what I mean and I probably
understand you you gave a logical
perspective for this audience but I mean
a reg X is a much more natural sort of
uh control structure so presumably you
can handle any reg compilation given the
the DFA interpretation right yes yes uh
I think that's a very important followup
uh we are kind of looking at considering
like compiling DFAS to to circuit and
and kind of automate all these process
yeah so acl's in January there I mean I
think they'll love it um your initial
example you you wanted winter to you you
wanted the presence of winter to select
for warm right which is more of a
natural language entailment and I don't
think you handle that right you you you
Handle Variations inflectional variation
because I think I think we can totally
take take uh do that winter example um
so
basically
um let me go back it seems like you
encoded the specific variations you were
allowing right oh Oh you mean like so so
we can have winter Winters but like
maybe if the winter the word is not
explicitly mentioned you cannot do that
something that's what I understand from
your formalism right if it's if it's in
your Ora you'll generate it if it's not
you won't you won't capture the
entailment no yeah I mean so basically
so that's the other thing so so
sometimes people or most of the time
people uh want to have like kind of soft
control they don't they can't really
write their uh constraint in in logical
form for example toxic um like can how
can you tell a sentence is toxic but
there are many ways to approximate it
one of the ways is we have like a long
list of phrases or words that you're not
allowed to use yeah in a toxic sentence
and we can basically just uh write down
a logical formula approximating that
toxicity constraint does that yeah I
mean there L of plug andplay generation
tricks that are actually quite
interesting I think that um so so
basically there there's a of course
there's naive way to to do it um um you
can say whenever I encounter one of the
word in the list I just remove like
prevent it from generating prevent it
from being
sampled but that that's not exactly what
we're trying to do probabilistically
right so sure no but I I just maybe
looking the plug andplay controlable
generation it's actually a paper yes so
where I think they're doing much more
than that right well so there yeah so so
it's like they're also modifying the the
the posterior selection so so if I'm not
uh wrong if I remember this correctly
they're basically trying to train some
sort
of they they use a classifier right and
yeah so basically kind of they're trying
to train a neur model to approximate
this yeah one right so but but they're
so yeah so their methods has has like
two disadvantages compared to our
advantages so one of them is that they
cannot guarantee that this is right 100%
like logically right satisfiable and and
the other is that they have to retrain
their model for all different
constraints yes okay but uh okay suppose
suppose like uh in their training data
they're only trained to kind of like
satisfy they only have seen like using
uh say less than 10 keywords to generate
a sentence right what if today I want to
use 20 keywords they would not be able
to generalize well to that one right so
I their example is toxicity right so
they they pre-train for toxicity they
can use that anywhere so there's some
some tasks that you're just gonna used
repeatedly I guess I think I see a
combination of what you're doing and
what they're doing together which gives
you this sort of entailment during the
like like this broader sense of
satisfaction right which which which I I
I think was a interesting motivation you
didn't quite deliver one but you could
deliver on um that's actually the
current project we're working on so
we're trying to combine the models that
can handle like soft constraints with
with our model too okay beautiful um and
finally I mean the the reason large typ
of models work so well is just is
because of a tension right and so you
know when you're using a hidden Marco
model right you're losing the power of
attention but but I guess I'm I'm I'm
looking at this and trying to convince
myself that well you get all the
attention in the right hand part and
then you just need a a little bit of
bias of selection in the left hand uh
part here and that's that's what's
happening Yeah so basically intuitively
you can think of this part as only
providing like guide and suggestions
leading the model uh leading uh GPT to
satisfy the constraint but on this part
it's kind of responsible for fluency
grammar and everything yeah yeah
okay beautiful work thank
you all right thanks maybe we should uh
wrap up and uh thanks again um
and um we can have lunch with the
database folks and talk about generating
SQL quer